My opponent tonight
is Cameron Esposito
who just released
her new comedy special,
the proceeds of which
she's donating to charity.
Comedy doing good in the world?
I just don't see it.
Cameron Esposito, everybody.
-Welcome. -Yeah!
-(applause and cheering)
-Welcome.
-Thank you so much, Jordan.
-Happy Pride Month to you.
Yeah. -It is?
I'm always prideful
to be in America, so, uh...
Right. No, but...
-This... -...to me,
it's always Pride Month.
Well, but this one's
really Pride Month, so...
Yeah, I like to think they're
all really prideful, huh?
No, this is the one, though.
You think
this is the special month.
-This is the special month.
-Well, I'm happy.
-That's good.
-Yes, thank you.
-Yes. Happy Pride Month.
-Thank you. Yeah.
I want to talk
about your special.
It's got quite the name.
Your comedy special is called...
It's called... Rape Jokes.
-Yeah, that's what it's called.
-That is what it's called.
That's what it's called.
I thought we weren't supposed
to talk about those things
anymore.
Well, no,
we can talk about them.
I mean, we should also joke
about everything.
-Um, I am... -That's what
I've been telling people.
-Yeah, just be good at it.
-Oh, okay. Well, I...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Okay, okay.
-That's the difference.
-Okay. All right.
I mean maybe you can't
tell rape jokes,
but, like, I'm a very talented
comic, and I can.
Okay. All right, I'm starting
to see where the line is here.
-Yeah. -So, what is
telling a good rape joke?
What does that mean?
Well, I think, if you're talking
about a taboo subject
or something that really affects
real people,
you have to give it weight,
and you have to expect
that there's going to be
survivors in your audience.
I'm a survivor
of sexual assault.
When I talk about it, I talk
about personal experience.
I'm very funny, but I'm also
very real, and that's what
I would just ask for
from other comics is like,
"Hey, um,
can you tell a good joke?"
How do...
how do they respond to that?
They love that.
-You know, men love
to be challenged. -That's...
-Really? -And when I say that,
I'm usually talking to a man.
And men especially love
to be challenged by lesbians.
-(laughter)
-It's a...
It's a good challenge
for a lot of men.
So why... why...
why deal with this now?
This has been...
Your special has been lauded
as the most important special
in the #MeToo era.
Why is this important now?
Well, for me,
I remember the moment
that I heard the person
who is currently president speak
-about women...
-Mm-hmm.
...and the way
that he behaves toward women.
It was very dehumanizing.
I felt like an object.
I felt like a goal for him.
It turns out
we are 51% of the population.
And I have thought
about that moment ever since.
What's interesting...
You-you-you...
Your special does also talk
a little bit
about the comedy community.
You talk
about other male comedians.
Uh,
talking about sexual assault,
talking about rape in general,
and then who get upset
because, uh,
they feel that they're infringed
by other people saying
they can't tell those jokes.
Like, where is the line?
Who is being the snowflake here?
Well, I think that anybody
who can't take feedback
is probably, like,
not a great artist.
Like, tell a good joke.
Tell a joke
that doesn't do harm.
Have a point. Have...
Move the conversation further.
Be an artist who cares enough
about your art
to be good at it.
And I feel like some comics
take that one bit of criticism
and they internalize it
as oppression.
It is not oppression.
I also... I-I get a lot
of feedback because of my job.
And I expect it, and, I mean,
it happens every day,
and, um, I use it to make myself
a better comic.
Do you think...?
If people don't know the-the...
the comic community,
is this a tool
that is being used
in the community?
Do you feel like are you pushing
back against a force
that is moving
within the comedic community?
Do you mean, like...
-Do mean rape jokes? Do you mean
are folks... -Like rape jokes.
-...telling rape jokes?
Is that the question? -Yes.
That is. Well, yeah.
I didn't want to say the word
-as many times as you...
-No. Yeah.
...but I'm still getting
comfortable saying it.
Rape jokes have been around
for...
I've been doing standup
for ten years.
I've been doing comedy
professionally for 15.
Rape jokes are a perennial...
It's a perennial topic.
There's even that little
phrase-- "rape jokes"--
we know what we mean by that
if you're a part
of the comedy community
or if you pay attention
to standup at all.
It usually means, like,
a comic gets on stage,
and they just throw out
the word "rape."
It doesn't have, um,
a punch line.
It's to get
an audience reaction,
a cheap laugh
because you've said something
that most people don't feel
comfortable talking about.
Just a word that is taboo,
and I...
What I am pushing back on
with this special...
It's an hour
about sexual assault
from my perspective
as a survivor.
But it's also really funny.
Like, it's...
I mean, I am openly going
to tell you, it is funny.
(laughter)
And I'm very proud of it
because I think this is a way
we could reframe
the conversation.
Like, not all comics...
We're not a monolithic field
where everybody has
the same views.
Um, folks have different
perspectives, and this is one
that I don't think
we have heard before.
Cameron, my favorite question.
Yeah.
Tell me something
I already know.
Um, well,
you already know that...
this is a great look, and...
(laughter)
...if you're a dude,
and this doesn't work for you,
I'm fine with that.
Her comedy special Rape Jokes
is available
on her Web site,
CameronEsposito.com.
Cameron Esposito.
The fight continues.
-♪ ♪
-(applause and cheering)